GOOD VICTORY, GUYS!
GOOD VICTORY!
HEY, HEY, COME ON, GOOD GAME!
SLAP-ASS, MAN!
HEY, GOOD GAME!
GET SOME SLAP-ASS!
[laughs]
YEAH, DOG!
YES, MAN!
GOOD GAME!
SLAP-ASS!
[laughs]
HEY, WHO'S NEXT? WHO--
HEY, GARCIA!
COME ON, MAN, GET YOU SOME.
COME ON, LET'S GET
SOME SLAP-ASS OVER HERE.
- NO!
- WHAT? WHY--WHY NOT?
- I SAID NO, RAFI.
- HE'S HAD ENOUGH, RAFI.
WE'VE ALL HAD ENOUGH.
- ENOUGH OF WHAT?
- ENOUGH OF THE DAMN
ASS-SLAPPING, RAFI.
- GRACIAS.
- THE [bleep] SLAP-ASS?
- SI, YES. SI.
- MM-HMM.
- [laughs]
GUYS, WHO [bleep] CARES
HOW MUCH I SLAP ASS?
SO WHAT?
I SLAP ASS!
NO BIG DEAL, MAN.
I'M A [bleep] BASEBALL PLAYER.
THAT'S WHAT WE DO.
WE [bleep] HIT HOME RUNS,
AND [bleep] SLAP ASS.
COME ON, HUH?
- RAFI, THAT'S NOT
HOW WE ALL SEE BASEBALL.
- EVERYBODY DOES IT.
ALL THE TEAMS SLAP ASS, MAN.
YOU--
YOU SLAP ASS, GARCIA!
- LIKE, A COUPLE OF TIMES
A GAME.
- [laugh sheepishly]
WHAT?
SO WHAT, MAN?
WHY THE [bleep]
YOU COUNTING, MAN?
WHO KNOWS HOW MANY TIMES
I SLAP ASS, OR HOW MANY--
- 427 TIMES.
- OKAY, TIME FLIES WHEN
YOU'RE HAVING FUN, MAN. WHAT--
- MY FAMILIES COME
TO THESE GAMES, RAFI.
MY SON IS ALWAYS ASKING ME
WHY I'M LETTING THIS MAN
TOUCH MY BUTT SO MANY TIMES.
- AND YOU SAY "SLAP-ASS"
EVERY TIME.
- EVERY TIME!
- OKAY, HOLD ON ONE SECOND.
LET'S GO TO THE TIME-OUT.
I'M FROM
THE DOMINICAN REPUBLIC, OKAY?
ALL I KNOW,
SINCE I WAS A LITTLE KID,
IS TO CATCH FLY BALLS
AND TO SAY "SLAP-ASS"
EVERY SINGLE TIME
I [bleep] SLAP ASS!
- THIS IS THE MAJOR LEAGUES,
RAFI.
WE ARE ALL FROM
THE DOMINICAN REPUBLIC.
NOBODY HERE HAS EVER HEARD
ANYONE SAY "SLAP-ASS"
BEFORE YOU.
- QUIT PLAYING, MAN.
COME ON, GET YOUR SLAP-ASS.
all: RAFI!
- RAFI, ENOUGH! OKAY?
- I'M...
[sighs]
OKAY.
YOU'RE RIGHT.
I KNOW YOU'RE RIGHT ABOUT IT.
I HAVE A PROBLEM, OKAY?
I KNOW THAT.
AND I DECIDE TO STOP
RIGHT NOW.
- BUENO.
- [sighs]
RIGHT AFTER I GET
THAT GARCIA SLAP-ASS.
COME ON.
all: HEY, HEY, HEY!
- WHAT?
- NO, RAFI!
- HEY, COME ON, EH?
I'M FINE, ALL RIGHT?
FINE, I GET IT!
- [sighs]
[all struggling]
- GET UP OUT OF HERE!
- COME ON!
- GET OUT OF THE LOCKER ROOM!
YOU GET OUT
OF THE LOCKER ROOM!
- YOU'RE THE ONLY SLAP-ASS
THAT MATTERS, GARCIA!
- YOU ARE NOT
GETTING A SLAP-ASS!
- HEY, GARCIA, MAN,
CAN I TALK TO YOU FOR A SECOND?
- OH.
- HOLD UP.
- HEY, RAFI, WHAT'S UP?
- OH, MAN, I JUST TALKED
TO THE MANAGER, MAN.
HE SAYS HE'S GOING
TO TRADE ME, MAN.
I MEAN, WHAT THE HELL, YOU KNOW?
I GOT KIDS, TOO, RIGHT?
- YEAH, WELL, WE ALL TOLD YOU
WHAT WAS GOING TO HAPPEN
IF YOU--
- HEY...
[heavy breathing]
I REALLY COULD USE
THAT ONE SLAP-ASS, MAN.
- RAFI.
- COME ON, MAN.
JUST ONE SLAP-ASS, YOU KNOW?
JUST ONE--
JUST FOR OLD TIMES' SAKE,
YOU KNOW?
GET ME BACK ON MY FEET.
I REALLY--
JUST ONE FOR THE ROAD, MAN.
I COULD REALLY USE IT.
[heavy breathing]
OKAY, OKAY.
GOOD GAME! SLAP-ASS!
[loud smack]
[relieved sigh]
- I GOT TO GET HOME
TO MY KIDS.
- OKAY.
OH.
GARCIA, MAN.
I'LL SUCK YOUR [bleep] IF YOU
LET ME SLAP YOUR ASS AGAIN.
- NO!
- [groans]
GARCIA,
I'LL SUCK YOUR [bleep].
[groaning]
OHH, SLAP-ASS, SLAP-ASS,
SLAP-ASS, SLAP-ASS, SLAP-ASS,
SLAP-ASS, SLAP-ASS.